john is with us in atlanta hi john
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thanks for having me sure how
can we help
well dave i'm calling in because i'm 27
years old
um i've got a stable job with the
federal government that pays pretty well
and i'm just kind of looking forward
at my future here and it seems like
a lot of the people who stay in this
position
kind of end up losing passion for what
they do and um
i'm starting to notice myself losing
passion for what i do
and so you know when i bring this up
with my family they kind of tell me
um you should stick with it you've got a
pension there
um you know you've got ironclad job
security
but i feel like if i stay here i'm gonna
i'm gonna go crazy
i wanted to know i'm 27.
how long you been there man two years
how many two years two
and what is it you do exactly daily
um well i work as a statistician so
basically i'm you know they they try to
automate a lot of the things that my
organization does now
and so i'm involved with with that
what do you love doing man
well um i i do love
working with numbers i do love um
statistics it's what i studied in school
why is this driving me crazy then
well it's driving me crazy because i
just don't uh
i don't know it just doesn't seem like
the people who work here
are are very passionate about what they
do i mean
um yeah you're i don't let's don't care
about them for a second
what about you it's okay to be in a room
where you like what you're doing even if
the people around you don't
um no because the problem sorry the
problem is that
what a lot of the times what ends up
happening is that if you're passionate
you know you end up getting extra work
but because of the way the system works
there's not really
there's not really much advancement so
it just becomes frustrating
what what does the word passionate mean
to you
i've been hearing my students use that
word passionate for years
now what what does that mean to you
well i suppose that what it means is
that sometimes
you know if you wake up in the morning
and you don't want to do something
and it's okay to feel like that
sometimes
but if you feel like that day after day
after day
um then that means that you lack passion
so passion means that
i guess over a long period of time you
can look back at what you've done
and say you know i really enjoyed doing
that
that really that really made me feel
like i was doing something
important
good answer okay so what's the downside
with you
going to work someplace else
well i would lose um i would lose my job
security for one thing
security there's no such thing you work
for the federal government brother
yeah they lay people off
they lay people off too they're probably
not gonna go broke i don't think
but um but they lay people off too and
your job you're only as secure as your
ability to do
things that people want to pay you for
and if you're a statistician who likes
statistics you're going to be
employable for a long time in a
data-driven world
yeah this whole world's driven off of
data right now and you're a data analyst
if there ever was one right
right yeah i mean i suppose that you
probably can make twice as much money
yeah if not three times yeah i'm sure
yeah i'm sure it's just a you know
security
security is an illusion dude it's a drug
brother yeah you need to get out of
there
um because i mean you're 27 years old
project this out you're going to be 57
30
years of doing this you already sound
old right now i can't imagine how long
you'll sound then that's a great line i
was trying to think what he's not
depressed but you just sound old man
you sound 74. yeah don't you know can
you imagine how old you're going to be
when you're 57.
good god you'll be a thousand
in government years
yeah hey listen the people around you
the people who
who are giving you advice um they mean
well but they're just wrong
they yeah they are telling you they love
you in the only language they know how
which is
you being safe and you'd be insecure
which we know is an illusion but they're
doing the best i can with what they got
and at some point you've got to get off
the drug
of safety get off the illusion of safety
and jump
so john one of my heroes was my grandpa
in the great depression
uh he was 27 years old oddly enough and
he
in the in the stock market crash he lost
a business and went
and went broke and alcoa aluminum had
come to alcoa tennessee
in the hills of east tennessee and
opened a plant and he went to work for
them
he worked there 38 years and never left
because of the fear
partly because of the fear of having
gone broke when he was young
and partly because he was a good man and
wanted to provide for his family
and the stability of that was there
in that environment my grandmother
became really dependent upon that
security that you're talking about
and uh humorous story uh the first time
i sold my millionth
book i've sold about 20 million now
about the time i sold my millionth book
which means i had made
millions and millions of dollars okay if
you can imagine
my grandmother called and still was
worried about me
running my own little business when are
you gonna get a real job dave that's
exactly what she said
she called up and said honey i'm worried
about you when are you gonna get a real
job and i had just sold my millionth
book
now she's sweet and i understood where
she was coming from because i know the
story
and my grandpa was my hero and i
understand
he's just one of my favorite people that
i ever knew on this planet
i miss him greatly to this day but the
uh
and i loved her i loved her too as well
she's sweet as she could be
but in her that was her love language
from the environment and the situation
the way they had lived life
was to say when are you going to get a
real job and she meant
well uh john just like the people in
your life mean well
but i had just sold a million books i
think we can safely say the
data the statistical evidence is that
she was wrong
okay and here's the thing if you go out
on your own
and you give it three four years and it
doesn't work my guess is
you could probably get a job got your
job right back that's right maybe not
that exact one with that exec department
or whatever but whoopty dopedy
uh you you have a marketable skill in a
data driven world
data is the businesses that don't
understand grasp and harness
the date the power of data in the next
decade will be out of business
correct it's not optional so you are a
highly sought after
individual in your world and so that
that's
um i'm telling you i think you're
probably making about half or maybe a
fourth of what you're worth
and you're giving it all up in the name
of security that's not really there
anyway
get out yeah you can just hear i can
hear your soul leaking it out
it's leaking out of your body out yeah
oh get out get out
get out yeah there's something there's
something to be said for i want you to
be safe
and so i want you to drown slowly right
i want you to be safe well i don't think
everyone should be an entrepreneur no
absolutely i don't think everyone should
be on straight commission i don't mean
that but
you know you're only as secure as your
own ability to land the next thing
because you have talent
yeah and people want to work with you
yeah yeah
marketable skills and personality and
so forth that's your that's your only
real security because everything else is
smoke and mirrors the guy making the
payroll he's
he's scared too yeah and you think
you're secure
that's funny you know